[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i did a podcast not long ago and i
spilled water all over my laptop there's
always something going on yeah
technology is not my friend you know
what i mean i try real hard but it just
it feels like by the time i i'm not even
old but it feels like by the time i get
something there's a new thing breaking
yeah you're buying like the the
the version right before the one you're
always about to have i feel like that
too a lot yeah it's like you get a you
get a new computer and then you're like
all right now i'll get a new camera and
then the new camera films in 4k and then
you're like oh yeah my computer can't
handle it let's get it
and it's just like it's endless and they
got to be working together to just keep
making stuff to keep making you buy more
stuff that's what i think we might as
well just get right into it uh welcome
on to the seventh episode of the joke
world podcast uh amazing guest today you
all know him love him you see him on
netflix uh netflix is a joke festival
touring comedian all over the country
dusty slay all right thanks for having
me i'm pumped to be here yeah thanks for
coming on you know we talked about all
these technical difficulties and even
now right on the video is if i look down
the circles are gone but my face is dark
but if i look up boom now there's
circles in my eyes yeah you look the
same here both ways but it does kind of
maybe change a little bit and we're
talking just how that happened right
when i started introducing you my
background went from the logo i had to a
blue screen literally right as i was
introducing you so i'm gonna just flip
that over real quick it's funny we're
talking about technical difficulties and
there we go just made it so much better
this is how it is doing these podcasts
on zoom um a lot of technical
difficulties but we'll be able to get
through it i think have you been doing a
lot of podcasts uh recently i saw you
just on whiskey ginger
well since um
yes since
um
netflix came out i've done a ton of
podcasts i do a lot of podcasts in the
country music world
okay so i did a lot of you know country
singers podcasts and stuff like that uh
a few comedy ones i you know i did
whiskey junior ginger most recently
and now i am a regular co-host on the
nate land podcast with nate bragatzi
nice so um yeah a lot going on and i
have my own podcast that i do um you
know pretty sporadically but uh i still
do it so you and nate are some of the
biggest uh nashville comedians that you
know based out of their theo move there
theovonne recently is there a
big uptick in like stage times and mics
in nashville i feel like it's becoming
kind of like austin in a way a new
comedy space
well we don't have as many like clubs we
have one great club zany's and then you
have um
you know
if you're if you're in with zany's it's
really great because you you get to do
there's a monday night show every night
or every monday every week
um and it's really great and then i have
a show that i do monthly other comics
have shows they do monthly and then
there's other random showcases
and there are some rooms around the area
i mean nashville is just great in
general
but i feel like if you're up and coming
there may not
be as many opportunities for you
you know there are some but i feel like
there may not be as many whereas austin
i think has a ton of i don't know as
much about austin i've done the moon
tower comedy festival there and i had a
lot of fun
uh and i i understand that they are
getting more clubs
so
austin may have more going on than
nashville but yeah i think nashville is
a better place to live have you seen um
because like your persona on stage and
some other guys like maybe theo van you
you have like a real maybe country like
uh theme or like it's not even like
maybe on purpose it's just who you are
and it works really well for you guys
because it's very authentic have you
seen anyone coming into maybe nashville
seen being like i want to be a comedian
based out here that kind of puts it on a
little bit maybe tries to do like a fake
southern southern comedy thing i don't
know i feel like that could happen you
know but um
i think you know what happens with me
is like you know i grew up in alabama
right now i grew up real southern real
country and then you know i moved to
charleston south carolina for 10 years
and now i'm i'm back in nashville and
it's like
a bit of my accent went away right but i
learned to be funny
as a southern country guy so when i get
on stage
it's like i go back into that where i
feel like my accent gets a little
heavier on stage and i'm not doing it on
purpose it's just how i've learned to be
funny all growing up
yeah and you know but i'm just like
every day walking around in my life i'm
not trying to be funny every moment of
the day you know yeah so
but it's hard to say i don't think
there's really anybody personally that i
know that's faking it
but i think
i heard someone say the other day that
when you're on stage you're like as a
comedian you're like a heightened
version of yourself
so it's like some comedians want to be
on all the time and that seems
exhausting i don't know why anybody
would want to live like that yeah but
for the people who aren't on all the
time it's like yeah we get on stage and
we come alive you know that inner
comedian comes out
yeah um
and um
you know i think that's what happens
is there a difference in like uh alabama
where you grew up southern versus like
nashville southern because nashville i
feel like is still like obviously you
got broadway i'll like country music hub
but it's it's not like the most southern
place it's pretty in the middle i would
say of
of the actual country yeah i think so i
mean nashville is even different than
you know just tennessee around it you
know nashville's got its own vibe i mean
it's still very southern here but uh
yeah i mean
where i grew up and and where i grew up
is not even so country but my wife's
canadian right so she really notices the
difference when we're in nashville
versus when we go visit my hometown in
alabama
and we just went down to dauphin island
which is um you know on the very tip
it's a little island just below
alabama and it's still part of alabama
but it's you know it's a mostly
undiscovered beach area where there's
not a lot going on but the whole island
is a beach so
you basically have a private beach all
the time so if you're like me and you
want to go to the
the the you know i want to go to the
beach for the beach you know i'm married
i got a kid i don't care about the bars
i don't care about partying
i just want to go hang out on the beach
and relax and that's a great place but
you know it's a different vibe down
there i mean as my wife would say you
know who's canadian she's like just a
bunch of fat southerners down here
getting sunburned on the beach you know
yeah and she's right
yeah you know but that's what i'm into
yeah it doesn't sound bad to me i'm i'm
in tampa right now i moved here about a
year ago and the beach is here like
tampa bay area like clearwater st pete
they're fun but they are slammed with
vacationers yes like they have like the
private
like ten areas all lined up you gotta
really find your spots and uh yeah you
don't really just go to the beach for
the beach you're you got a little area
you can't really move around you can't
go toss the ball around like a year
crowded beach is really no good it takes
away the whole point kind of
yeah and tampa's really great i've been
there many times but i don't think i've
ever been to the beach while i'm in
tampa yeah you know i go there for
comedy and that's it yeah
so uh you come around here side
splitters is is that the main yeah i did
the um the improv years ago and then the
you know the from probably 2016
on i do side splitters okay
some of the people that i talk to for
for this podcast are people in town
doing sidesplayers and i can grab them
do an interview real quick and most
people i get the vibe that it's one of
the best uh
clubs maybe in in the country would you
say you have a favorite club besides
your home one zany's uh that you get
excited to go to on tour
well i do
really like side splitters i think it's
a lot of fun you know any of those old
school clubs like that where they just
really have the old school vibe it's uh
it's a lot of fun i mean
yeah i would say that's one of my
favorites i like you know the comedy
catch and chattanooga i think that's
really fun but you know there's also a
lot of the new clubs are really fun uh
milwaukee wisconsin just got a new club
it's huge
and i always say i don't like the huge
clubs but it's awesome you know it's
like
it's like there is an old school
mentality with the old school club
sometimes you don't really get like the
club's great they built up this thing
over the years
but like you know you go to these new
clubs and it's like they roll out the
red carpet you know what i mean you're
like so it feels nice to be in there
yeah maybe an old school club like it
gets the
the romance of it being old in many
years there but they probably aren't as
inclined to do these red carpet because
it's like oh that's how we've always
done it we can you know treat people um
not bad but probably that you know the
same way that they always have and then
the new club it's like we need people to
come in here you know let's let's give
them throw everything we got at them
yeah i mean it's like from from one week
you know i do a club in uh you know
lowell arkansas called the grove and uh
when i do it i always stay in this cabin
[Music]
and people
they'll go oh man you're still staying
in that cabin and i'm like i like being
in the cabin but the guy will fly he has
a private jet he'll come fly to
nashville and then fly me into the grove
you know and i'm like
it's tough to beat that kind of stuff
yeah it is yeah the cabin does not sound
bad when there's a private jet attached
to it also
so you were just in um
you said you mentioned you were at moon
fest uh in austin and then you were in
the uh netflix is a joke festival too
right
yeah i didn't do
moon tower this year i did it
either
exactly early early 2020 or late 2019.
okay but i did netflix as a joke
festival just recently nice i was at
moon tower this past year and it was a
blast it was a ton of fun but so so
gearing up for these festivals is that
any different than just going to do a
road gig and as far as preparation goes
for you
i don't think so i mean it's
different in the sense that uh there's
industry people around so all the um you
know
all the important people in the comedy
world uh are hanging out and could
potentially be at your show
so where is like normally you're like
you just go up you do comedy you know
you care that it goes well i want it to
go well because i care about comedy
but
if it doesn't go well it's okay right
but i don't really want to bomb in front
of the biggest industry in the country
you know yeah there's a little extra
pressure but you know i don't even know
if they were at my show but i also feel
like i work well under pressure
so that doesn't really affect me that
much
were you there around the time that the
dave chappelle thing happened i was
there after i wasn't there at the same
time but i the security really got
heightened after that in fact
even i had my own personal security
guard netflix had for me so wow
at all my shows they came to my show
they stayed until i left that's pretty
cool that's a good response yeah when i
left the venue they left but they stayed
uh even i did a show on friday and then
i got asked to do a second show and the
security guard stayed
wow so
i felt like it was really unnecessary i
feel like i could use an attack on stage
i could use the press yeah that'd be
fine for me
um that sucks it out i mean i heard it
rock sales went up really big when he
got slapped i mean
i i would take a slap for for
upping the ticket sales you know so you
heard it here first i've been slapped
for no money before that's a good way to
think about it
if anyone out there is at dusty's next
few shows and he's feeling bold
he welcomes a slap yeah in fact i've
never got paid for getting punched you
know i've been punched many times and
it's always for free
how much would you take how much would
it take for you uh any random person can
just punch you at any time but it's just
throughout your normal life someone gets
to buy a one-time pass so whenever they
see you they're allowed to just sock you
what's that number for you oh it would
have to be a lot because you take a
sucker punch like that at least up on
stage you can gear yourself up but you
know it's like that whole hand who was
it uh whatever the stunt man was that
said uh he could take a punch from any
person
uh and then he got sucker punched and
then he died wasn't that harry houdini i
think yeah man yeah houdini yeah it's
like i don't need that kind of drama in
my life right you know yeah i don't
really want to get punched
but i guess my point is uh chris rock
and dave chappelle's attacks in the end
seem relatively easy
and uh i would take the ease of that for
the uh drama
of some ticket sales you know what i
mean
my ticket sales are doing fine so i
don't really need to get that
that guy that attacked dave chappelle i
think like two weeks later i saw he got
like uh
arrested for like attempted murder of
his roommate like he was just he was
just
he was done being part of society i
guess and if he didn't get arrested at
dave chappelle yeah i mean uh it's never
shocks me when a person that attacks
someone is guilty of attacking another
person yeah you know
i mean i got relatives that have been on
drugs and
they get off drugs and then they get
back on drugs and everybody's like i
just don't know what happened and i'm
like well they're a drug addict you know
that's what happened yeah
yeah it's a it's an astute observation
there and the level of person this guy's
attacking like one of the greatest
comedians in the world and just his
roommate like it's it's crazy he's got a
lot of range
for his for his terror yeah exactly i
mean
it's like you would think once you
attack dave chappelle would be hard to
get hush again yeah you're not gonna get
that same rush from attacking the
roommate yeah
yeah don't start at the top where's the
fox at where is where's all these guys
stomping me it's probably so boring to
just attack one right now yeah i mean
but i guess you know i mean i guess
chappelle's pretty ripped but you start
trying to attack jamie foxx i mean that
guy is uh
i don't know he always seems pretty
ripped to me
yeah
it's like will smith it's like you know
he played ali you know or and and also i
am legend you know i mean he's like
the last surviving man on earth if he
comes attacking you you know you don't
but i don't know and i don't know if
he's not that big you know i've done
coming up i've done comedy in the
southeast in the midwest i mean i've
done comedy in clubs all along the way
that felt like i could get attacked at
any time has there ever been a close
call where you said something and you're
like oh this this person might actually
do something well it's hard to say who
knows when it's a close call or not i
mean i was at a bar and or a club in
johnson city tennessee which is the far
east side of tennessee
uh where it gets it gets real hillbilly
out there i got a lot of friends from
east tennessee but it can get real
hillbilly out there real quick
and
there was two middle-aged couples there
and they kept you know
going back and forth there's only about
12 people in the whole club this was
years ago
and the four of them is a drunk two
drunk middle-aged couples and they kept
going at me and i kept going back with
them
because the show wasn't going that well
anyway so at this point i didn't care
i'm just dealing with some drunk couples
yeah and i see the manager of the club
kind of back out of the club like he
felt like drama was about to go down and
he was just going to get out of here
yeah but after the show i saw those two
couples one of them i was standing
over by the front door and they came out
the side door of of the club and i saw
them trip over a trash can and fall into
the street
and i just thought geez yeah you're like
50 year old people out here
so drunk you can't even stand at a club
blackout and it felt like i
burned them even though they did it to
themselves it felt like i won in the end
that that is a win for you that was just
smoke
and they were you know of course i put
the cigar in the ashtray of the hotel
earlier before my show and after that
show i dug it out of the ashtray to
finish it off because i was stressed
that's a savvy and uh
and that seems like a low point when
you're smoking a cigar out of the
ashtray but then you see the people you
argue with trip over a trash can and
fall into the street and you're like i
win yeah at first sounded like it could
have been a loss you're on the second
hand cigar but then they gave you a gift
and and fell over right in front of you
that's that's great
yeah you know and you know i was in a
club in san antonio one time and there
was a couple in front and they kept
talking to each other
and i was like hey what are you guys up
to here and the guy go he's mumbling
along and i was go what he goes i'm
getting laid tonight and i was like oh
well you better get out of here then
yeah you know it's like just go do it
don't ruin my show yeah because you're
worried about getting laid just go get
laid dude just go
yeah what are you doing here if that's
if that's the case anyway
yeah i mean if you already know i
thought that's what the comedy show was
for you take a date to the comedy show
if it goes well you get laid that
if you already know you're getting laid
get out of there yeah you're doing it
do you um do you find it hard to kick
people out of the show or are you ready
just if you're interrupting you got to
get out well i get more ready to kick
them out all the time because i'm like
what i like to believe is that if
somebody starts to disrupt the show and
then you go you say something to them i
don't like to insult them that's not
what my comedy's about i'm not trying to
come out here and insult people the
whole time i just want people to listen
to my jokes right and then and then i
tell them and they laugh and then we get
out of there some people have it in
their minds that comedy is crowdwork
and
that's just not my kind of comedy there
are comics that do really great crowd
work
and i do okay with crowd work but that's
not what i want to be doing
i want to do these jokes that i've wrote
right and
so i want to believe that i can say a
little something to them we laugh i move
on they not do it again yeah but it just
feels like nowadays
they're just going to keep doing it
yeah so i like the other night i was in
a club and
this guy started talking and i was like
it just irritates me so much
that it's hard to turn it off it's hard
to hide right you're getting like
actually pissed just like you'd
leave you know and then i was like you
know what i don't want you to leave
actually i don't want you to leave i
just want you to be quiet you know
and it's like i'm up there and i am
having a good time i'm not putting on an
act i'm waving i'm saying we're having a
good time and i am but the moment
somebody like says something now
there's different ways that people can
say things somebody can yell something
out from the audience loud enough for
the whole audience to hear i can make a
joke about it and then we all laugh and
it's a good time yeah or they can be
close to the stage and they can say
things that only i can hear
and those are the worst
because it digs into you but nobody else
can hear so nobody knows it's going on
yeah but i was doing and then i was
doing a club the other night and it was
a really great set it was really going
well and this guy yells out he goes work
the crowd
and i'm like jesus dude like yeah that's
absurd come out here and go hey what do
you do for a living you know i know
comics do that and a lot of them are
very good at it yeah but that's not what
i want to be doing right and that's just
absurd for somebody else for a living so
just demand like stop with your written
jokes that you actually work every day
on you know start talking to us like we
need some attention that's an absurd
thing to yell during a show yeah it's so
and then i looked at the guy oh man and
i wanted i wanted to throw him out of
there right away
but it's not something it's not worthy
of kicking the guy out right but but i
get it you know there's a a singer uh
named ray lamontagne
and i don't know if you've ever heard of
this guy i'm sure you've heard some of
his songs but he's a real kind of soft
singer he plays guitar real soulful kind
of stuff and i heard one time that
he demand and i don't know if this is
true i just heard it that he demands
complete silence in a show
and if people talk during his show he
gets really irritated and throws them
out of there
and when i heard that i thought that's
ridiculous yeah but you know 12 years
into comedy i'm like oh i get it yeah
you know what i mean
i get it yeah especially because he's
like i'm trying to do this for you it
will be better if you just shut up and
like and they don't want to let it's
like he's like it's for your own good
i'm trying to do this for you
and yeah that's do you think people say
they go well you should be a better
comic you know you got to be you got to
be able to handle that stuff and it's
like it is true that you need to be able
to handle it
but it doesn't mean that i need to be
good at interacting with hecklers
and doesn't mean that they need to
manufacture it like you need to be good
at handling that if it happens for real
not like a real heckler gets offended by
or whatever from a joke that you wrote
and told not people being like i have no
issue with the show but i think that
this is what i'm supposed to do so i'm
just going to start
yelling stuff out and be like well you
can't handle it it's like well that
wasn't even necessary that wasn't even
like that wouldn't have happened if you
didn't you know what i mean like you can
you need to handle it
yeah that's crazy do you think that yeah
you should you say i need to be able to
deal with it i say you need to not put
me in that situation yeah exactly do you
think that all these clips get like it
we're in a real uh shift in comedy
online where everyone is constantly
sharing clips uh like stand-up reels
stand-up clips tick tocks and it seems
like majority of those are crowd work
probably because you don't have to burn
any material and it really engages the
the person on their phone being like oh
this you know i knew this wasn't written
like this just happened
for like so real so like do you think
that all these clips getting shared of
crowdwork is is causing maybe more
people to be like i want to go to a show
and maybe i'll be in the clip or you're
supposed to yell stuff
out yeah i think so i think that is
what's happening because i i typically
share
crowd interactions or riffs that happen
to me so i'm not burning up material
like you said
but i it is organic when it happens for
me i do i have heard of some comics that
at the end of their show they'll do a q
a
[Music]
and the q a will be just for their clips
okay so it's like it is really happening
but it's the comedian asking for
questions from the audience and then
making jokes yeah and it's okay people
can do whatever they want but i just
feel like it's not organic if i'm
sharing a crowd interaction it's
happened to me on stage right one of the
coolest things i saw at moon tower this
year i went to uh stand up on the spot
and that was that was cool to watch
because everyone knew that that was
what's supposed to be happening like
people are supposed to be yelling out
the topics and then there's and then
there's like it was it was fun to be
involved in in the show but like
responsibly or like that's literally the
whole point of it but then you go to
other shows and there's people yelling
stuff out and it's like
it just makes me uncomfortable like
sitting next in the area people just
like
ruining a show it's just it's a strange
thing to do yeah i can't stand it i i i
do like that i used to do a show
probably in
2011 or so when i was living in
charleston me and two other buddies we
had a show
well we would only get about a half hour
at this theater and we would do 15
minutes uh five minutes a piece of our
regular material
and then we would spend the next 15
minutes taking words from the audience
and then we would all three make a joke
about that word
and because we had different styles of
comedy you got to see
where each of our minds took that word
to make a joke about that's cool and it
was really fun
you know it was a i thought
at the time i don't know of anybody
doing that but i also wasn't connected
with the rest of the comedy world so who
knows
but the um
and and that's a lot of fun you know a
gimmicky type show it is fun to see but
yeah i mean i just feel like with covid
with like people being locked up in
their houses and now suddenly being out
again i feel like people have forgot how
to act
and um they just everybody wants
internet material they forget that we're
living in reality yeah and they want
internet material yeah like i like to do
a lot of gardening and i'm always like
oh i should film this uh you know for
the internet and then i'm like no i this
is what this is me doing something
that's not for the internet yeah people
you forget that you have to do like just
things for the sake of doing them
sometimes which is kind of scary it's
like
like we have to live life it's like
everybody they're like oh i'm cooking
let me film it yeah you know let's see
i'm guilty of it i got a video on the
internet that's done pretty well of me
cooking in an insta pot you know
but it's like i've also cooked you know
a thousand meals since that time but no
one has seen you do that so i don't know
if i believe you
right exactly yeah and and and if i'm
not getting likes is it even worth it
the meal sucks without some likes it
tastes
so much worse without likes that's no
it's so wild it is so wild and um
it's weird and it's just the
encouragement to do it is there
everybody's pushing because it works
right the more content you put out the
more followers you get the more tickets
you sell sell and it's like
the the model works yeah but it drains
you of all your life yeah then you're
just yeah nothing is real anymore do you
do you have you found it harder to um
as you've been as you've been like
growing your career starting to headline
these clubs and these people are coming
out just specifically to see you
going back on uh
people in the crowd do you find it
harder to remove people or maybe slam
them a little bit
because now you're the guy that they're
coming to see where maybe earlier in
your career if they're being annoying
they might not even know who they're
what lineup they're there to see and
you're just like get out of here but now
there is there any additional pressure
or sentimental value i actually i think
it it all gets better right because if
it's an audience of people there to see
you um
they're they're likely not to do that
yeah and then if they are if they are
doing it you can make fun of them and
the rest of the audience is on board
with you
you know it's like they're there to see
you so
it makes comedy easier when people are
there to see you because they already
know a little bit of what you do and
there's less time to get to know you
yeah that's going to be the worst also
you know there's less chance that the
audience wants to yell at you and if
they do yell at you
it's usually something positive or some
kind of joke request or something like
that yeah that you know
i don't mind i don't mind if cause if
somebody yells out a joke they want me
to do it's like for me it's like oh
that's great they know my material and
they want to hear that joke i may not do
it i may not even remember the joke
they're requesting at least how to tell
it all the way
but it's nice it feels good to be like
all right you know my stuff yeah yeah
that makes a lot of sense that's like
yeah it's encouraging it's not even
really heckling at that point so you if
you do remember it though you're you're
likely to do a request if someone really
wants it
yeah i mean i did a show i mean it's
hard especially if i have like jokes
that i really want to do right now you
know say say i have two shows a night
i'm doing the early show and i got i got
jokes that i really want to do
adding another joke in there can be hard
you know just for time's sake
yeah but i yeah i mean i was in
knoxville one time and we just had one
show i'd never done shows in knoxville
and at the end of my set a guy yelled
out a joke
and i was like oh okay i'll do that joke
and then i did it and then somebody
yelled another one and somebody yelled
another one and i bet i did you know
20 minutes or more of joke requests oh
that's cool and it was really fun to do
and it was like you know there was no
time that i had to be out of there so it
was like yeah let's just roll with it
yeah that sounds like the dream because
it's it's like just playing your
greatest hits at that point that's kind
of cool yeah you know because you know
sometimes that's what it is for comedy
it's like i got a lot of jokes that i
really like and would love to tell but i
you know i did them on the tonight show
or i did them on netflix and you know
i'll repeat some you know just because i
like doing them but for the most part i
try to do all new jokes yeah so how is
your
uh process coming up with new jokes like
you're right do you use are you a pen to
paper guy are you on stage just work it
out
i'm more of an on stage work it out you
know um i find that you know sometimes i
do need to write the idea down when it
comes to me or i'll forget
yeah
but yeah i mean for the most part i like
to just go and try to work it out on
stage
i find that
i don't know
early on i was all about pen and paper
but now i find that on stage i can just
get up there and you can rely on those
natural instincts that made you funny in
the first place yeah i feel like a lot
of people
in school making people laugh i wasn't
writing it down going all right i'm
gonna say this next yeah you know you're
just popping out with stuff yeah that's
that's when people be like their true
voice i feel like starting out in comedy
like doing open mics and stuff it's like
i need to like write down something like
a set up in a punch line or try to be
edgy or try to do this or that or try to
do how you the guys that you watch that
you like like what their style is or
whatever but then once people realize
like what why do i think i'm funny
enough in the first place to even be
doing this at all like what what makes
me funny when did i think i was funny
it's like oh hang out with your friends
like at the lunch table that kind of
stuff like if when you're not thinking
about what you're about to say you're
just kind of like going off of
the conversation at hand and and you're
not writing that down exactly like you
said i feel like that's like
when people start to get good is like
when they become they're just talking
how they just literally are just how
they exist and not trying to be a
comedian if that makes sense
yeah totally and you know i feel like
this this comic i know he had this idea
he said you know comedy is like a tree
right and you and and the main part of
the trunk that's your act that's your
jokes and then you're going up and then
when you when you want to go off on a
tangent you know you kind of go out on a
limb
and you keep going you keep going and
when it gets you get too far out there
and it starts to bend the joke's not
working as well you bring it back in
back to your act
and i feel like that's a good analogy
probably a good redneck analogy but it's
like
i
that's what i like to do i like to you
know i'll have i say sometimes you know
my joke ends long before i stop talking
right because
i'll get big laughs and then i'll keep
trying to milk the joke yeah you know
i'll keep
doing stuff until
until we're not even laughing anymore
and then i'm like all right we're having
a good time and we get out of there
right but it's like that that to me is
fun yeah it's like we already got a good
laugh out of it i gotta i feel like i
got a good laughs per minute type type
ratio in my show where i'm like punch
punch
so i'm like yeah if we we can waste a
couple of lines if it's worth giving you
know worth trying to get a new laugh is
that something that you at any point
ever like actually sat down to calculate
like
i want this many laughs per minute or
was that just a natural flow of like the
jokes that you write
yeah it's just a fear of being on stage
without people laughing
basically you know it's like
if
um you know about um we're having a good
time
and um
i wonder if that i just adjusted
something that i'm wondering that
changes the volume and if it does i'm a
little idiot but
uh i did a ted talk on on we're having a
good time and you know the first part
that i wrote of the ted talk was jokes
yeah and so i'm like i'm hitting the
jokes and i'm going all right that's
great and then once
i
um
once i started getting to a more serious
part the audience stopped laughing and
i'm like oh no i'm bombing
but there were no jokes right so it
wasn't bombing
yeah and i
i didn't like it i mean
it um
i blanked out and then i just started
telling jokes from my act because and
then at once i would get more
comfortable then more jokes would come
or more part of the ted talk would come
to me but
oh my god i don't like the serious stuff
that's that's really funny that's
probably speaks to how
how natural of a comedian you are that
you're supposed to be doing a ted talk
but without the laugh it's just like you
just got to go back to my act
that's great yeah it's like i'm on stage
and i just feel like when i'm on stage
i'm on stage to do comedy yeah
so do you think that it's hard to like
tell a longer story or something that
might take like two minutes to set up or
maybe you even have to like pretend to
be like real serious for like two
minutes like try to really set up a
longer joke do you
try to stay away from that because it's
uncomfortable when no one's laughing to
even set up a premise or is that fine
because you know that the the payouts
coming
it's much harder for me to do that um
i
um i have a joke now that i'm doing
where um
i it's a three minute joke
and i you know the story has a good
punch at the end but you know but it's
more of a story so i've been learning to
tell this story
and as time goes on i do have punch
lines now throughout where people
where it is getting laughs
but in the beginning
i did it at the grand old opera it was 4
000 people in the audience and it's a
three-minute joke and i'm used to
getting laughs about every 15 seconds
right i get a little bit of something
right um
and for three minutes no one laughed
they just looked at me
and i was like man if this punch line at
the end doesn't pay off yeah this is
gonna be the biggest bomb i've ever had
i think okay and
fortunately i hit the punch line at the
end the whole place laughed and it was
like well worth it yeah so that's what
you know i got afraid of that in the
beginning because that's what they
always say you know if you're gonna have
a long story with one punch line at the
end then that punch line better be worth
it right yeah okay no because i got a
lot of jokes where
there's not really much of an ending to
the joke but we're laughing all along
the way there's so many punches all
along the way that by the time that
jokes ends i just move right into the
next thing yeah and it's like it's not
so much about closure for me it's just
about uh it's not the destination it's
the journey right a la and a laugh is a
laugh so if it's
along the way or at the end it doesn't
matter
that's what i say all the time i say you
know that joke doesn't have a real
ending but we had a lot of fun along the
way yeah and that's the joke in itself
too it's just because like yeah i think
a joke's supposed to have an item so
then you addressing that it doesn't it's
that's a whole other joke there too yeah
you know i feel like i'm influenced by a
lot of people but like uh mitch hedberg
has a couple of his on his albums i
remember him saying stuff like that's
not a full joke there yeah and he does
it in his way and i i feel like i've
picked that up in a sense where i'll do
things like that yeah it's just like i
don't know steve martin and mitch
hedberg both had uh
uh an influence on me just in kind of
the silliness of what they would do
where it's like yeah i'm writing jokes
and my act is funny but it's like if it
if a joke doesn't work let's not get so
bent out of shape you know let's not
take it so seriously yeah we are just
telling jokes up here yeah that's one of
the things that i i really feel like i
picked up on when i was at
that last festival i just attended
because i saw
seven hours of comedy at night for like
five nights in a row just like
professionals just just getting after it
and it was like when they're trying new
stuff or like something doesn't go well
or made the crowds dead and a joke kind
of falls flat
the comedian addressing that to the it's
like so much funnier than them just like
moving on or being like just trying to
get to the next joke or like acting like
that didn't happen when they're just
like oh gee like all right moving on or
like all right you're not gonna like
this next one either just addressing
when that doesn't go well just gets a
huge laugh like every time and that's
like wow i
like that makes so much sense like we
can't forget that like we're we all know
what's going on here and it's way
funnier to address what's happening than
try to act like that didn't happen
yeah and it's like to me it's like that
that is so much the part of being funny
is like uh growing up you're like
joking away your mistakes or joking away
your
uh i don't know the word but whatever
you're uncomfortable about any of your
self-consciousness you're like oh that's
how you joke it away yeah so bombing a
joke and and joking that away
that's all part of it yeah like that's
how you learn to be funny in the first
place yeah at least me i mean i guess
different people learn different stuff
but it but
for me that's what it's all about you
know
making a mistake and then being able to
make a joke that that everybody forgets
the mistake because
you're so funny about it do you find it
harder as a established name now trying
out brand new things where it might be
so silly that you're like
i don't even know if i wanna like try
out a new a new joke unless i know that
it's 100 don't like this is gold
well for me i never know what's going to
be gold right sometimes i'll think of
something and i'll go this is going to
be fantastic and then i go tell it and
no one laughs and i can't understand why
and i may keep telling the joke for a
long time just because i don't
understand why the audience doesn't
think it's funny right but then if you
think it's
what's that and then if you think it's
funny there's got to be something there
i'm like yeah you know and that's what i
heard one time if you think a joke's
funny and the audience is not laughing
then you've just not figured out how to
write it yet
and i think that's probably true i mean
i got a joke in the middle of a bit now
that i that i wrote years ago
and it never worked actually i have a
joke about the waffle house that
probably happened to me in
2010 and i just started doing the joke i
mean i wrote it down you know 12 years
ago
and i just started doing it
because i i tried it once on stage
it bombed and i go well i guess there's
nothing there
but then i remembered it
and i just started doing it again and
now it's a huge hit for me it's a great
joke
wow so it's like
you know it's just you become better at
comedy and some of your old ideas are
better now because you're funnier yeah
yeah that's that's that's a good point i
guess you don't think of either is like
you keep getting funnier ever do you
think that you get funnier every
every year of your life like or at least
from starting comedy like is there any
limit to how this is kind of a broad
question i guess is there any limits out
funny that you you can get
i don't know i mean i think
that
as long as you're always working it
right you're always on stage and as long
as you
stay up to date with what the culture is
doing right i feel like this happens to
a lot of older comics
is they lose touch with what the culture
is doing or they just stop caring
and then they just seem out of touch and
i think it's hard to be funny when
you're out of touch
yeah you know it doesn't even mean that
you have to agree with everything that's
going on it doesn't mean that you have
to
address it but you have to know where
things are going right to know what you
can and can't say i mean and it's like
that seems weird to say in
in a you know a free speech kind of
society but it's like
it's just the way it is right it's like
when you start saying stuff that the the
culture has moved away from
then you become irrelevant you know
or or if you're not working it but i
also and this is not something i've
dealt with so i don't know
but i feel like it must be harder
for super popular comics and rich um
to write new jokes because
uh the audience loves you right and they
just think you're so funny oh yeah yeah
yeah that they're laughing at all your
stuff yeah so it's like are you still
being funny like if you were to get
dropped in front of a group of people
that had no idea who you were would you
be funny to them yeah i feel like that's
a lot like i try try listening to like a
brand new podcast
like that's like 150 episodes in it's
like i don't even get
half these references like if but like
there's a million people following this
like everyone it's hilarious everyone
because they know what's going on or
they just love whatever these people say
like they're going to love it so that's
and when people get like
astronomically wealthy from doing
stand-up i feel like it can be hard to
be like
telling jokes that are relatable to the
to the people listening because the
audience is going to be just an audience
you know
right when you're when you're never
around uh normal people you know like if
it's like
because even for me right like i'm like
i just fly all the time because i'm
always doing gigs right so i'm just
flying every weekend right so i fly with
one airline so my status got really high
with that airline to where i have the
highest status that you can get with
that airline
so i get upgraded to first class i've
never bought a first class ticket but i
get upgraded probably 80 percent of the
time
to first class and then they offered me
this kind of uh club
that you know you go to the airport and
you sit in the special room you know
with the airline yeah and it's like
it feels so phony to me like it feels
like i shouldn't belong in first class
or in the club
yeah i'm like oh this is the best i got
free coffee i got free snacks i'm away
from everyone i got better wi-fi i got
more comfortable chairs
of course i want this but it's like how
do you how do you write jokes about like
yeah i was in first class the other day
and then i had all this arm room yeah or
whatever it is yeah you guys know about
the lounge it's like if you're no longer
relatable
right yeah exactly it's like it's like
if you're not relatable to what people
are up to but
those things i think are just a small
like i think a lot of people can relate
to that so i don't think but i but i
mean
once you actually get wealthy i don't
know what that's like
me and my wife
about that the other day it's like she's
like i don't think that you'll ever
become like that because you like
picking up stuff off the side of the
road too you know yeah she's like it
doesn't matter how much money you have
you still want to pick up a computer
chair off the side of the road you know
if it's a good deal
yeah
i can't resist i have a table on my back
porch that my neighbor threw out the
other day
i mean i i totally get it i just i'm
like oh that's
able are you gonna throw that out free
stuff feels so good and you feel like
you you got i don't know what people are
up to just throwing things out no
uh i i saw um what was it the the
bit about the uh chairs unlearn the
chairs at uh oh yeah yeah you know it's
funny i forgot i even told that joke but
that eat some patio chairs and
the wood it was very good metal chairs
yeah it wasn't like i was trying to dump
trash out of goodwill right but the the
seat was wooden and broke it had a good
cover it just needed a new bottom to it
which would be easy to do especially if
someone's in woodworking it shows how
much money everybody actually has that
even goodwill's like now we can't sell
these chairs that could be easily fixed
yeah
yeah and and and uh you know some lady i
don't know i don't know who it was it
was a man's name and then i signed off
with a woman's name on youtube lecturing
me about that joke and i was like you
know they're like you shouldn't just
dump your trash off at goodwill and i'm
like
well it wasn't trashed they took the
table
it was a metal table with a glass top
they took it but i got three chairs off
my sister was there with me she was
moving all slow
and she wouldn't get the fourth chair
and then the the goodwill guy was like
nah we can't take these we can't take
this load it back up and i didn't know
where to go with it i didn't have a
truck at the time right so i'm like
let's just go over here to this big lots
and throw it in the trash
which what else are you gonna do i mean
yeah right she's like well they may
videotape your license plate and you may
get fined and it's like fine you know
what i mean if they find me they find me
but
i need somebody to come pick this up
yeah
uh i feel like goodwill's kind of stingy
with the stuff that they that they are
willing to accept like here's three
pretty good chairs and then
what's wrong with this i mean they're
they just want like brand new stuff at
goodwill that defeats the whole purpose
right it's like you know it's a good i
mean i guess they think well we'll never
be able to sell these but it's like to
me that shows like even people shopping
at goodwill are like
nah i don't have i won't fix
these
i need chairs that are already in
perfect condition yeah there's a trend
going on on tick tock that i see where
it says
it's a you know a voice audio that
people are using and it says you know
uh you're not good at being poor right
and it's like just showing that it's
like if you're poor
but able-bodied
you can still have good stuff
just take something that's bad and make
it good yeah but nobody wants to make
anything good they want they just want
the best stuff and if it's not the best
they just want to you know
the lazy throw it in the trash can't be
poor and lazy that's not a good
combination
right i think that's the audio yeah you
can't be poor and lazy yeah that's fine
and it's like it is true i mean i love
to build stuff i mean it's so great
yeah and it's rewarding i'm not even
that good at building things but i like
doing the process of building i built
the desk that i have that i'm sitting on
right now and it's been creaking the
whole time i mean anytime i move off of
it it creaks it makes a lot of noise i'm
sure there's a way to fix it but i don't
know how but i had to replace wood off
my back porch and i took some of the old
wood that was still good and i built
this desk and then i sanded all the wood
and then i stained it and it's great
that sounds really fun too it's a whole
it's a whole process
yeah
i'm going to get drilled holes in it so
i could put the mic stand inside of the
desk i mean wow and you can be proud of
it too i think you're frozen for a
little oh there you go okay i put on our
community section questions for you uh
first to see if we had some people
sending any questions there's a few
interesting ones i want to hit here at
the end someone said do you think that
alabama has a potential to develop a
formidable economy scene maybe in cities
like birmingham or mobile
well i hope so i don't know birmingham
has a club they have a club called the
star dome i think it's all about someone
just doing it right it's like huntsville
alabama has a really good club
and it's doing really well and i
wouldn't say the stardome is a bad club
i think
they've
they've created an ad model
where they give away so many free
tickets and it's like you can't do good
shows with free tickets right right
but i think if you're a draw you can do
the stardome in birmingham it could be a
lot of fun because people she will come
and pay tickets
but mobile is interesting because i was
just in dauphin island which is about 45
minutes below mobile
and i just can't understand why mobile
wouldn't have a good club but you know
new orleans doesn't really have a club
either and they're all kind of right in
that coast
so i don't know what that is uh i did
shows and i did i opened for bert
crusher at a theater in new orleans one
time and it was really fun the audiences
really came out it was really great and
then recently i opened for fortune
feamster in mobile
and the same thing we had i mean me and
fortune were walking down the street and
people were just pouring out of the bars
to meet fortune
like it's like everybody downtown was
downtown to see her show wow now some of
the people knew me but they were really
pouring out of the streets for her
and i'm like so there clearly is enough
people to make a good club yeah but i
don't know sometimes i think that in a
certain area it's like people want a
certain kind of comedy and there just is
not enough
comics of any certain kind of comedy to
give people
a consistent thing you know it's like
right there's the comedy zones and they
have the it's a chain they really branch
out uh you know they they franchise out
all these clubs and so if you become a
comedy zone the comedy zone has a uh a
lineup of comics that they'll send your
way
but so many of those comics are not good
so yeah
what's that they just get in with the
comedy zone and now they're on the
roster yeah it's like i guess you know
i'm saying they're not good and i guess
that's relative because people do like
them but i just think overall it's it's
a it's an outdated model right like so
many of those comics have been with the
comedy zone for a long time
so
you know you you get this club and then
all right people come out and they go
this is my theory
people come out and they go all right we
got a new club in town let me go see
some comedy and then the first week it's
like some old school road comic doing
jokes from the 90s and you're like okay
well that wasn't really my thing but it
was only one time we'll go back next
week and we'll see and then you go back
next week and it's the same thing
so you're like oh okay well i won't go
back there yeah and then you and then
people that like that kind of comedy are
coming and that is a dwindling audience
right you know yeah and then it's even
hard then you set your whole club off
based off that type of comedy those type
of fans and then when you can get a a
guy on the road maybe like yourself or
something like now it's a whole
different thing so then the normal
people are coming out to see something
different
and and it's not what they expect and
then you're trying to get your people in
there and it's like the people that like
the old 90s comedy are now seeing
something fresh and they're like oh i
don't like that so then the booker goes
well i'd love to book you but you just
don't work in my clubs yeah it's like
you made it this way you you did it
exactly yeah yeah that seems like a
terrible system but i think mobile does
have the potential i mean because i did
a theater show
with fortune and i don't know how many
people at least a thousand people yeah
so it's like they are there do you think
that it's just like i've heard this
about i think i heard mark norman say
this about new orleans it's like they
just have too much too much other stuff
to do they're like they don't want to
just sit and silently and listen to
someone and talk like there's too much
party and stuff to go on there maybe do
you think that could be
at play in some of these areas well that
could be true you know this thing could
be said about nashville and that's
what's great about zany's is zany's is
outside of downtown not far outside but
it is outside it's like
i don't think a comedy club in downtown
nashville works right because on
broadway yeah or there to party yeah and
they don't want to sit down and maybe
that's the problem for new orleans
uh mobile i don't know i don't know how
much partying is going on but i do have
just the theory about alabama in general
it's like during football season
nobody it's like
it's like friday night is high school
football yeah saturday night is college
football and sunday is pro and it's like
alabama loves football right so who i've
always actually wondered this who's
alabama um
who's the nfl team that most people root
for growing up in in alabama well
growing up i we always like the atlanta
falcons because i grew up on east
alabama so i'm two hours from atlanta i
was 15 minutes from georgia
in alabama you have to be eight you have
to be 19 to buy cigarettes and there's
no lottery so when i was 18 i would
drive to georgia for cigarettes and
lottery tickets that's how close we were
okay and then um
but yeah atlanta was mainly the team but
you would also uh the miami dolphins i
liked yeah and a lot of people will pull
for the saints they're pretty close why
do you think that they've never tried to
like have a pro
influence there i think it's because uh
alabama football college is so big yeah
that makes sense because i mean it's
practically a an nfl team
uh with just
i mean it's i the
stadium seats over a hundred thousand
yeah i mean they're selling out most
games what about what um
what what's his name just said jimbo
fisher about nick saban just really like
i think it's wild i mean i don't
understand what's just happened i guess
i'm out of the loop i mean i saw what
jimbo said yeah apparently college
players are getting paid now i guess and
i missed all of that it's only been a
whole year i don't really understand the
argument
yeah i love it i mean i i love that kind
of rivalry where it's like you know
everybody's got to be sick of nick saban
like i love you yeah but it's like nick
saban's been dominating for
i don't know 14 years in college
football a godly run like no one has
ever even like belichick didn't do that
like this is different like no one even
wraps her head around what nick saban
has really done like yeah so he's been
so i get it everybody is tired of him
and i get it but i also love it and it
makes sense like the stuff that jimbo
fisher was saying like he just basically
just kind of called him an [ __ ] it's
like yeah he's no one thought nick saban
was like the most loving like
if you're nick saban if you're that
great at being a college coach you're
definitely an [ __ ] like look at what
urban liar like all these guys yeah you
devote your whole life to it i i never
thought nick nick saban would be a good
hang yeah yeah
yeah dabo sweeney looks like a good hank
but nick saban doesn't no you know that
was obvious i've never been like i would
love to toss him back with nick saban
just kind of
right right yeah that'd be a blast huh
yeah yeah
but i'd love to pick his brain about
football i'd be kind of scared i would
be like
very timid like that's how it is though
it wasn't that surprising all right
we'll do one more question uh this is
another interesting one i love talking
football i always get off off topic
talking to football but this is a back
to comedy what is it like being on
fallon and co jimmy fallon and conan and
they also said who's better if you what
show you like doing better
well i was uh i was on fallon and kimmel
uh i never got to do component which is
uh really bums me out uh because i would
have liked to do that actually i was in
talks with the conan booker one time
and then i don't know what happened he
never liked my videos i sent i don't
know what happened but then i got booked
by jimmy kimmel in the meantime
um and then i've been i've gotten to do
fallon three times so my experience uh
you know has been great with both but
now that i've you know i've done fallon
three times
and ultimately that's what gave me the
big push kimmel it was almost like a
a practice run because i had never done
a late night before so it was like my
intro to what that's like okay and then
so by the time i got to do the tonight
show i was better prepared yeah um but
both of them couldn't have been nicer to
me jimmy kimmel was so nice
um he came over he talked with me a bit
before the show
um and then he said uh
and i don't know if you've uh uh the
person asking the question has actually
watched it but
there's a noticeable difference in how
my set go like i did a lot of those
jokes on my netflix special because i
wanted i never felt like those jokes my
trailer park jokes i never felt like
they got a good
uh time in the sun you know because i i
wanted them to be on a late night but
then they just didn't go that well and
i'm like that's not a fair
representation of how good those jokes
go yeah so i'm like i'm doing them on
netflix yeah and
but i just um
jimmy kimmel came up to me right before
and he goes this is a weird audience
tonight so whatever you get out of them
you earned
and a lot of people think that's a bad
thing to say to me but i loved it yeah i
was actually like that gave me a little
confidence because i was like all right
i may not do real well yeah at least
jimmy kimmel just told me that you may
not do real well yeah yeah takes the
pressure off and then if it doesn't go
that well you you're not like
embarrassed that jimmy kimmel saw it
because he's the one that told you like
what the deal yeah yeah yeah jimmy
kimmel goes this is a hot audience
tonight you're about to quit and then i
go out and they're not laughing i'm like
oh
yeah he's like it was a hot audience
yeah yeah but fallon you know i've
gotten to do that show three times and
he has always been so nice to me he
always comes by talks to me um and
you know um
the booker for jimmy kimmel i i uh she
hooked me up i had never done a late
night before and it was so i'm so
thankful that she
booked me but you know fallon really
gave me the break that i needed yeah
what's the um like behind the scenes
like there is it really nice like like
how like
like private entrance or green room kind
of like like being on the show is it uh
are you whined and dying
yeah i mean they really take care of you
i mean they've always put me up in a
nice place um and they come in they pick
you up from the hotel even though it's a
very short walk they still come and pick
you up
and then you know in the backstage it's
really fun it's like because you just
see other people who are gonna be on the
show
like you know i saw janet jackson
backstage one time i saw um i think it's
blake russell the nba player backstage
one time
um
uh you know mark maron came up to me i'd
never talked to mark maron oh he was on
there pushing a tv show he was doing and
i was on there doing comedy so i guess
you know both of us just being comics he
came over and talked to me for a bit and
i was just like that's amazing yeah that
is cool
did you notice um you said that the the
uh fallon gave you more of like a of of
that bump a lot of people say nowadays
like podcasts like going on like joe
rogan or even like this past weekend is
like would be way bigger for a
comics career than the late night shows
nowadays a lot of people like to say
maybe late nights time has passed but do
you think that you did get a good bump
on your social medias on your views or
ticket sales after going on those late
night shows like what do you what do you
think about the landscape of late night
i mean i think that that they're right
um uh a big podcast can
uh really lift you up but it's like
podcasting is not what i do best right
right stand up comedy is what i do best
so i i can talk all day i can say all
kinds of things but comedy is what i do
best yeah so it's like i would rather be
known for my stand-up than for my
podcasting
you know um
that's great but it's like when i did
fallon the first time
fallon if you really crush it on there
that gets the industry really involved
with what you're doing
and that's what happened for me i did
fallon i got new management i got agents
and it's like you know i've been i've
been headlining clubs uh non-stop since
my first appearance on fallon wow
and so it's like
you know and and you know um
living in nashville not living in l.a or
new york i don't really get invited on a
lot of the big podcasts i'm not upset
about it i get it i'm not around
right but so i mean i you know give
credit where we're uh where people have
helped me you know and late night has
really helped me yeah and that's so
that's something i never
thought about i guess maybe because it
seems like nowadays it's like any
exposure is basically just all
towards like it's all just like clips
views everything in one bucket just
towards like a career it seems like but
i never really like realized like yeah
you get to do stand-up on those shows
that's why it's different maybe it you
know more comedy fans are like i'm gonna
follow everyone that's on
jre this week rogan whatever but you
don't get to do stand-up you just get to
talk about anything like aliens
government like it doesn't matter like
that's not what you're trying to do is
sell your stand-up tickets
that's a great point yeah yeah and it's
all about saying something crazy and
wild oh you know they you know you go on
and you say something crazy and then it
gets clipped up and
i got plenty of crazy stories but you
know i don't really i don't know i don't
really want some wild story clipped up
and then passed around a bunch going
viral to where everyone in my family
sees this wild story you know what i
mean yeah yeah yeah
i love telling a wild dirty story as
much as anyone but i'm like i don't know
it's just not as fun
to see yourself get clipped up and and
shown all over the world you know yeah
yeah and and it's got to be real like it
can't just be like oh i got this big
opportunity out of pocket what are some
of my crazy stories i have like maybe
we'll talk about like
it's not authentic that's like not what
people are into i don't think
you know
yeah i mean i think you're right
100
well i um
i do have to get going but i do
appreciate you having me on here yeah
100 i was just about to say thank you
again for uh coming on it was great to
meet you uh great to talk some comedy
with you and then if you have any dates
or any uh socials you want to plug real
quick uh for the youtube well yeah i you
know i'm launching my my second half of
the year tour i'm calling it the uh boy
named dusty tour uh you know is
reference to the johnny cash song boy
named sue and uh i hate tournament names
but we did uh
so you know dustyslay.com is my website
that's where all my stuff's at i have a
youtube channel um which is why i was
really happy that you you asked this
because you know you do your podcast on
youtube and i think my youtube channel
is my most creative and most unique of
my social medias because i have a lot of
different kinds of stuff on here
um but my website is dustyslay.com and
starting in mid-june i'll be in
huntsville alabama and then my tour will
start and i'll be
it won't be every weekend but it'll be
pretty much every weekend for the rest
of the year that i'll be out somewhere
doing comedy somewhere in the country
awesome book schedule go look it up
dustyslay.com we'll make sure to tag the
youtube in the description of this video
as well thank you again great to meet
you
yeah thank you very much i appreciate
you having me
[Music]
you